[Music]
and it starts when you see complex of
ancient Chinese buildings in Japan I saw
this bridge with a person riding their
bike on it the main character doctor for
pandas riding on a bike they were
studying and researching better ways to
release pandas into the wild because
they're near and stinking because of
habitat habitat loss then they go to New
Hampshire she went to New Hampshire so
she can see Ben's method of how to take
care of the bears they go and walks they
eat food they play where she was
skeptical at first I was skeptical I was
like mom what a skeptical mean and she
was like it kind of means that she
didn't believe all that much I was like
she's taking care of pandas you have to
believe in your pandas they chose
changing because they wanted a panda who
could climb who wanted to explore things
and had courage Jake was a calm the mom
like the dad likes the mom or dad for
attention because they were really close
it's like he knew the secret passage to
take care of pandas they put a tracker
collar on her and they let her go into
the wild
Jake was back in America he was taking a
jog he was doing probably his daily
routine because he really isn't jape and
then he was like oh let me look at my I
will see what Chinchin is doing he was
like oh my gosh he had to move for 24
hours oh my god is she gonna be okay and
that's when I started crying inside a
little like oh really who's my dad I
think you birth I hope she's alive
because this will be really sad if she's
not alive
and then at the end you find out that
she's fine
you
you